lots of clusterfuck let's go
[Music]
you don't see myself in that crazy guy
that's a Kevin Hart dog thank you for
interviewing me I am Gor burger so are
you excited to see at the festival the
door where's our show
I actually having in to think about the
puzzles as a ton of options I fell down
that's how big it is racial harmony and
a cookie look to the cookie Mitch hey
can I have some of your pizzas yeah you
can all have any rosanna sounds like a
great deal Cheers can I get a lobster
for crepes crepitus you know what you
want I'm not good for you it's hard
dancing this poorly I wonder how people
do it at music festivals all the time oh
do you want go to Paddy's Pub
[Applause]
[Music]
this has truly been colossal we'll see
you next year cluster fest car yeah you
carry me after party at alpha drove